>> Greg: ARE REPUBLICANS THE
PARTY OF THE WORKING CLASS WHILE
DEMS ARE THE PARTY OF THE
POMPOUS ASS.
ACCORDING TO AXIOS, THE WEBSITE,
NOT MY GREEK PERSONAL TRAINER.
DEMOCRATS ARE BECOMING THE PARTY
OF UPSCALE VOTERS WHILE
REPUBLICANS ARE BUILDING A
MULTIRACIAL COALITION OF
WORKING-CLASS VOTERS.
THE REPUBLICANS ARE BUILDING A
TENT BIG ENOUGH FOR BARACK
OBAMA'S BIRTHDAY PARTY.
AXIOS CALLS IT A POLITICAL
REALIGNMENT IN REAL-TIME.
DEMS ASSUME THESE BROWN AND
BLACK PEOPLE MIGHT BE
WHITE SUPREMACIST.
IT'S A SHIFT POLITICAL WATERS,
LIKE BIRD WATCHERS BUT WITH
FEWER FRIENDS.
THEY SAY IT WILL BENEFIT THE
RIGHT AND THE MIDTERMS
ESPECIALLY AS MORE HISPANICS
FLOCKED TO THE G.O.P. PROVING
THEY ARE LOSING INTEREST IN WHAT
CULTURAL ISSUES THAT IGNORE
REAL-LIFE CONCERNS.
THE RIGHT WILL COMPARE THEM TO
BREAKFAST TACOS.
ALTHOUGH THEY ARE DELICIOUS.
THE AMERICAN FEDERATION OF
TEACHERS COMMISSIONED A POLL
THEY THOUGHT WOULD PAINT
LIBERALS AND A GOOD LIGHT ASKING
VOTERS IF THEY HAD MORE
CONFIDENCE IN RAPINOE OR
REPUBLICANS DEALING WITH
EDUCATION.
REPUBLICANS GOT 39% OF THE VOTE
COMPARED TO 38.
IT'S A ONE-POINT ADVANTAGE BUT
NOT BAD FOR A POLL RIGGED BY
TEACHERS UNION.
NO WONDER THEY DON'T WANT TO
GIVE PARENTS A CHOICE.
WITH THE MIDTERMS CLOSING IN,
DEMOCRATS DESPERATE TO OVERHAUL
THEIR ELITIST IMAGE.
>> THANKS FOR COMING TO THIS
FOCUS GROUP.
AS A DEMOCRAT COME I WANT TO
TOUCH BASE WITH AVERAGE VOTERS.
YOU DIRTY FINGERNAIL TYPES.
GAS PRICES ARE PRETTY BAD.
VERY CONCERNING.
HAVE YOU TRIED TAKING THE BOAT
OUT ONLY TWICE A YEAR?
I DON'T OWN A BOAT.
NOT WITH THAT ATTITUDE.
>> I AM WORRIED ABOUT FEEDING MY
FAMILY.
YOU JUST DON'T GET IT.
>> MAYBE YOU'RE RIGHT.
MAYBE WE ARE OUT OF TOUCH.
WE ARE THE PARTY OF JFK AND FDR.
NOT AOC.
FROM NOW ON WE WILL PUT THE
CONCERNS OF HARDWORKING AMERICAN
FAMILIES FIRST.
>> HELLO.
OF COURSE.
I'LL BE THERE RIGHT AWAY.
I'VE GOT A 4:00 P.M. TEE TIME AT
THE COUNTRY CLUB.
I'VE GOT TO GO.
[APPLAUSE]
>> Greg: THOSE DAMN UBER USING
COMMIES.
DOUGLAS.
DO YOU THINK THIS IS REAL?
IS THIS WISHFUL THINKING?
IS THIS HAPPENING, THIS
TRANSITION?
>> THE AXIOS HEADLINE SPEAKS TO
THAT.
THEY ARE HORRIFIED WHENEVER THEY
DISCOVER ETHNIC MINORITIES MIGHT
VOTE REPUBLICAN.
THEY CAN'T UNDERSTAND IT.
THEY THINK HAVE THEY NOT BEEN
TOLD OFTEN ENOUGH BY THE
LEFT-WING MEDIA THAT THIS IS
JUST VOTING FOR THE KKK?
DON'T THEY GET IT YET?
THEY MAY THOSE -- THEY MAKE
THOSE PEOPLE HONORARY WHITE
AMERICANS AND WHENEVER THEY
DISCOVER THAT AMAZINGLY SOME
WOMEN VOTE REPUBLICAN THEY
BECOME MEN AND IT'S THESE GAMES
I NEVER TAKE IT SERIOUSLY.
THEY NEVER TAKE THE CONCERNS OF
VOTERS SERIOUSLY.
MAYBE THERE'S SOMETHING WE ARE
DOING WRONG.
MAYBE THERE IS SOMETHING WE ARE
NOT SPEAKING TO.
IT'S ALWAYS, MAYBE WE HAVEN'T
TOLD THEM OFF ENOUGH.
>> Greg: WE ARE THE ONES AT
FAULT.
SEEMS LIKE WHEN THEY GET INTO
POWER, THEIR ONLY PURSUIT IS
MORE POWER AND NOT THE NEEDS OF
THE VOTERS.
>> THE NEEDS OF THE FEW, THE
INDIVIDUALS.
IT DON'T THINK IT'S FAIR TO
DEMOCRATS.
MODERATE DEMOCRATS ARE KIND OF
STUCK.
IT'S LIKE IF OUR FRINGE SUDDENLY
STARTED DRIVING THE BUS, WE
WOULD HAVE DIFFERENT
CONVERSATIONS.
THEY'RE NOT ONLY DRIVING THE
BUS, THEY ARE DECIDING WHO GETS
ON THE BUS SO IF YOU'RE NOT IN
LINE WITH WHAT THEY'VE GOT, YOU
CAN'T BE PART OF IT.
THAT EXCLUDES JUST ABOUT
EVERYBODY BUT THEY ARE GROUP OR
WHOEVER THEY DECIDED TO BE.
THAT'S WHEN YOU SEE THEM COME
AFTER PEOPLE THERE IS NEVER
GIANT HOARDS OF PROTESTERS
BEHIND THEM.
THEY RELY ON TWITTER AS THEIR
SHADOW BANNED THAT GOES AFTER
PEOPLE.
SO I THINK WORKING CLASS.
THE ONLY ONES, HERE'S THE THING.
REPUBLICANS, WE HAVE TO DO
SOMETHING WITH IT.
WE ARE SAYING YES WE ARE HERE
FOR PARENTS AND SCHOOLS AND WE
ARE GOING TO GET THIS DOWN AND
GAS PRICES WE ARE TALKING A GOOD
GAME BUT LET'S SAY IN NOVEMBER
WE HAVE THE BLUE DROWNING AND WE
GET A BIG RED WAVE AND WE DON'T
DO ANYTHING THAT WE TALK ABOUT,
THIS IS GOING TO BE TOPSY-TURVY
ALL OVER AGAIN SO WE ARE IN A
GOOD POSITION RIGHT NOW TO GET
SOME THINGS DONE BECAUSE THE
AMERICAN PEOPLE ARE LISTENING TO
WHO'S GOING TO DO WHAT'S BEST
FOR MY DINNER TABLE.
NOT WHAT I CALL MY WIFE AT THE
DINNER TABLE, WHATEVER PRONOUN.
WE DON'T GIVE A DAMN WHAT YOU
CALL ME.
MAKE SURE THERE IS FOOD ON MY
TABLE.
>> Greg: REPLACE THE NEEDS OF
THE WORKING CLASS FOR IDENTITY
POLITICS.
>> THEY WANT NAME TAKES ON
EVERYBODY INSTEAD OF MEETING
PEOPLE.
>> Greg: KAT, YOU HAIL FROM A
WORKING-CLASS BACKGROUND, AM I
RIGHT?
>> NOEL.
MY FAMILY IS LOADED.
SORRY YOU HAVE NEVER BEEN
INVITED ON OUR LUXURY YACHT.
I THINK THE DEMOCRATS HAVE MADE
IT TOO EASY FOR REPUBLICANS.
FOR EXAMPLE WITH EDUCATION.
THE LONGEST TIME EDUCATION WAS A
NUANCED DEBATE OF WHAT KIDS
SHOULD BE LEARNING IN SCHOOL,
WHAT THEY SHOULD BE FOCUSING ON,
THE ROLE IN SCHOOL.
AND THEN DURING COVID, THE
DEMOCRATS TURNED INTO A DEBATE
WITH TWO SIDES WHICH WAS KIDS
SHOULD GO TO SCHOOL VERSUS NO.
YOU CAN'T BE SHOCKED WHEN PEOPLE
THINK SCHOOL IS GOOD FOR KIDS.
LIKE TYRA SAYS, I THINK THEY'VE
MADE IT EASY BUT REPUBLICANS
HAVE TO BE CAREFUL TO NOT TRIED
TO COUNTER EVERY SINGLE THING
THAT THEY PULL UP ALL OF THESE
DIFFERENT ISSUES.
THESE DIFFERENT SOCIAL ISSUES OR
IDENTITY POLITICS AND NOT TRY TO
AGGRESSIVELY COUNTER THOSE AND
FOCUS ON THE THINGS EVERYBODY
DOES.
>> Greg: FAIR POINT.
LEAVE THAT CLOWNS LIKE LIKE ME.
TALKING ABOUT THE PRONOUNS IN
THE TRANSIT STUFF IS FUN BUT THE
REPUBLICANS SHOULD JUST BE
FOCUSING ON CRIME AND INFLATION
IN THE ECONOMY.
THAT KIND OF STUFF.
THAT BORES THE PEOPLE AT HOME.
I'M KIDDING.
DOES THE SHIFT IN DEMOGRAPHICS
SURPRISE YOU?
I HEARD YOU TALKING ABOUT ON A
PODCAST OF HOW THE DEMOCRATS,
YOU'RE A DEMOCRAT, I BELIEVE.
>> I CALL MYSELF A LEFTY.
I DON'T KNOW THAT I WOULD CALL
MYSELF A DEMOCRAT ESPECIALLY NOT
IN THIS CROWD.
I WON'T MAKE IT HOME.
I THINK IT SHOULD HAVE BEEN
UNDERWAY FOR VERY LONG TIME.
50 YEARS AGO THE LEFT AND THE
DEMOCRATS WITH A SIDE OF LABOR,
WORKING CLASS.
THE REPUBLICANS THE SIDE OF THE
RIDGE.
TODAY YOU SEE A REAL SHIFT AND
WHO EACH SIDE SEES AS THEIR
BASE.
THE DEMOCRATS PLATFORM IS A WISH
LIST FOR THE OVEREDUCATED TOP
10%.
ENVIRONMENTALISM, BANNING
FRACKING.
THAT'S VANITY MORALS FOR THE
WEALTHY THAT PUNISHES THE
WORKING CLASS AND TAKES AWAY
THEIR JOBS.
DEFUNDING THE POLICE.
LIKE YOU SAID A COUPLE WEEKS AGO
ON "THE FIVE."
IT IS DURING THE KKK'S WORK FOR
THEM.
IT HURTS WORKING-CLASS PEOPLE OF
COLOR.
DEAD BODIES PILING UP BUT IT
MAKES THEM FEEL SO GOOD ABOUT
THEMSELVES AND HOLIER THAN THAT
BECAUSE THEY DON'T HAVE TO WORRY
ABOUT CRIME BECAUSE THEY LIVE IN
THESE UPSCALE NEIGHBORHOODS.
THE WAR IN UKRAINE.
LET'S FUND THAT.
GAS IS GOING UP.
IT MAKES THEM FEEL GOOD.
THEY ARE TAKING UBERSE, THEY
DON'T CARE.
THEY DON'T FEEL IT LIKE THE
WORKING CLASS.
THE AGENDA BUILT AROUND
FLATTERING THE VANITY OF LIBERAL
ELITES.
I TOTALLY LOVE WHAT YOU SAID.
THIS IS AN OPPORTUNITY FOR
REPUBLICANS NOT TO SQUANDER IT,
NOT TO JUST USE IT TO WIN THESE
CULTURAL BATTLES BUT TO MAKE THE
LIVES OF WORKING-CLASS AND
MIDDLE-CLASS AMERICANS BETTER.
SEE THE EXCELLENT POINT.
AND SHE WATCHES "THE FIVE."
THAT IS MY WARM-UP SHOW